APPEARS TO BE UNTRUE.
SHANNON.
>> Shannon: ALL RIGHT,
TRACE GALLAGHER, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
ALL RIGHT, WHAT DO WE KNOW NOW
ABOUT THE LENGTH CHINA WENT TO
TO DISGUISE THE TRUE MAGNITUDE
OF THE ORIGINAL OUTBREAK IN
WUHAN?
SOME BELIEVE IT AT THIS POINT WE
SHOULD BE BEYOND THAT QUESTION.
>> THAT IS A DISTRACTION.
I THINK THERE IS A LOT OF
INCORRECT THINGS AND TRYING TO A
LOT OF THINGS RIGHT, YOU KNOW AT
THE BEGINNING LIKE ANY COUNTRY
WHEN A VIRUS BREAKS OUT.
THEY CAN LOOK BACK AND SAY THAT
THEY MISS SOME THINGS.
>> Shannon: WHAT ABOUT CHINA?
LET’S DISCUSS THAT FROM
MIKE LEE, GOOD TO HAVE YOU WITH
THIS.
>> THANK YOU, SHANNON.
>> Shannon: OKAY, THE
BEGINNER, WE DIDN’T KNOW, CHINA
DIDN’T KNOW.
WHAT THEY LEARNED AND THEY
DIDN’T SHARE WITH US BUT WE ARE
LEARNING AS WE GO ALONG.
BUT HERE IS WHAT CHINA’S FOREIGN
MINISTRY SAID.
"CHINA ALWAYS STANDS AGAINST
THIS INFORMATION CAMPAIGN.
WE ARE A VICTIM RATHER THAN
PRODUCING THIS INFORMATION AND
PEDDLING THIS INFORMATION NO
MEANS DESCRIPTION FOR
ANTI-PANDEMIC COOPERATION AND
SHOULD BE REJECTED BY ALL."
WHERE DO WE GO NOW WITH CHINA,
SENATOR?
>> LOOK THE FIRST THING WE HAVE
TO REMEMBER IS THIS IS A
TOTALITARIAN STATE.
THIS IS A COMMUNIST
DICTATORSHIP.
CONSEQUENTLY, SURE, WE CAN TRADE
WITH HIM FROM TIME TO TIME IF WE
WANT TO TO THE EXTENT WE WANT TO
UNDER OUR TERMS.
BUT WE CAN’T LOSE SIGHT, SHANNON
THE FACT THAT THIS IS A
COMMUNIST REGIME AND THEREFORE
ONE IN WHICH YOU CAN’T REALLY
DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN A BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE AND THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT AND THE CHINESE
MILITARY.
THE THREE HEADED MONSTER, WE’VE
GOT TO ACKNOWLEDGE IT AS SUCH.
>> Shannon: AND YET SO MANY
AMERICAN COMPANIES HAVE VERY
DEEP CONNECTIONS COME OPERATIONS
THERE, SUPPLY LINES AND WE KNOW
ABOUT THE PHARMACEUTICAL SUPPLY
LINES.
IS THERE ANYWAY WE CAN "PUNISH
OR HOLD CHINA ACCOUNTABLE
KNOWING HOW INTERTWINED THE
ECONOMIES ARE?"
>> SURE, THE FACT THEY ARE
INTERTWINED DOESN’T MEAN THEY
HAVE TO BE TO THAT SAME EXTENT.
THE FACT THAT WE ARE MAD AT THEM
DOESN’T MEAN WE CAN’T HAVE ANY
TRADE WITH THEM.
BUT TAKE THE PHARMACEUTICAL
INDUSTRY IS ONE EXAMPLE.
WE HAVE SUBSTANTIAL
MANUFACTURING CAPACITY IN THIS
COUNTRY IN PLACES LIKE
PENNSYLVANIA, NEW JERSEY,
INDIANA, AND PUERTO RICO WHERE
WE COULD BE MANUFACTURING MORE
PHARMACEUTICAL PRODUCTS THAN WE
HAVE BEEN.
WE SHOULD BECOME LESS SUBJECT TO
THE WHIMS OF THIS COMMUNIST
DICTATORSHIP.
IN START WITH THINGS LIKE
PHARMACEUTICAL PRODUCTS.
SO LET’S ADOPT POLICIES AND
ADOPT CHANGES IN OUR TAX CODE
AND REGULATORY SYSTEM IF WE HAVE
TO IN ORDER TO BRING MORE THE
MANUFACTURING BACK TO THE
UNITED STATES.
THIS IS ONE AREA, ESPECIALLY
WITH PRESCRIPTION DRUGS WHERE I
THINK AMERICANS WOULD
VOLUNTARILY COME EVEN WITHOUT
ACTION BY THE GOVERNMENT,
VOLUNTARILY SPEND A LITTLE BIT
MORE, SAY 50 PER -- $0.50
WORTH 75% MORE FOR RESTRICTION
IF THEY KNOW IT WILL BE SECURE P
AND NOT
ONE THAT RELIES ON THE COMMUNIST
DICTATORSHIP.
>> Shannon: OKAY, TWO MORE
TOPICS WITH YOU.
FIRST OF ALL, THIS IDEA YOU WILL
BE BACK ON THE HILL POSSIBLY
TRYING TO HAMMER OUT ANOTHER
DEAL.
I KNOW YOU HAVE BEEN CONCERNED
WITH WHAT’S PASSED ALREADY, BUT
WITH RESPECT TO THE CRACKDOWN
SAYING WE WILL NOT BAIL OUT BLUE
STATES, REPUBLICAN SAYING THAT,
THE EDITORIAL BOARD SAYS THIS IN
THE MIDST OF A PHYSICAL CRISIS
TO SLIDE INTO A SECOND GRADE
DEPRESSION, MITCH McCONNELL
WOULD BE FOR STATES TO STIFF
CREDITORS FIRE OVER PAYING
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
WORKERS/HEALTH CARE AND
RETIREMENT BENEFITS AND CUT BACK
SERVICES TO MENTALLY ILL, THEY
ARE CALLING HIM OUT ON THIS IDEA
PUSHING BACK STATE BACKING FOR
FINANCIAL HELP.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I THINK I DISAGREE WITH EVERY
SINGLE WORD UTTERED BY THE
"CHICAGO SUN-TIMES," EVERYTHING
THEY SAID IS WRONG.
EVERY SINGLE CHARACTERIZATION
THAT THEY DEPEND ON
MITCH McCONNELL IS UNFAIR.
LOOK, THE FACT IS SHANNON, IF
YOU TAKE THE TOP FIVE STATES
WITH THE TOP HIGHEST PER CAPITA
UNFUNDED PENSION LIABILITY, THEY
INTERRUPT FIVE TIMES THE PER
CAPITA UNFUNDED PENSION
LIABILITIES OF THE MOST
RESPONSIBLE STATES.
WE CAN’T AS A FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AT THE TIME WHEN WE HAVE ALREADY
APPROPRIATED AND SPENT
$150 BILLION HOPE STATE
SPECIFICALLY DEAL WITH THE
COVID-19 EPIDEMIC.
WE CAN’T IN THAT SAME MOMENT TO
FIX ANOTHER PROBLEM THAT HAS
BEEN YEARS, IN FACT, DECADES IN
THE MAKING AS A RESULT OF
MISMANAGEMENT BY DEMOCRATIC
LIBERAL REGIMES IN VARIOUS
STATES.
WE CAN’T SUDDENLY CHANGE THAT
AND PRETEND THIS IS ALL
NECESSITATED BY COVID-19.
MUCH THE "CHICAGO SUN-TIMES"
WANTS TO PRETEND BUT THEY ARE
WRONG.
>> Shannon: SUPER QUICK, THE
SPEAKER’S IDEA THAT THERE WAS
POSSIBLY A WAY FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OR SHOULD BE TO
GUARANTEE A MINIMUM INCOME TO
SOME AMERICANS.
GO WITH THAT ONE HERE.
>> IF WE WANT TO BECOME WESTERN
EUROPEAN STYLE SOCIALIZED
DEMOCRACY, THAN THAT IS THE
APPROACH WE SHOULD TAKE.
THE FACT IS, SHANNON THAT HURTS
POOR AND MIDDLE-CLASS PEOPLE AND
THAT IS CONTRARY TO WHAT WE
BELIEVE ABOUT LIMITED ROLE OF
GOVERNMENT AND ABOUT THE ABILITY
THAT THE INDIVIDUAL CITIZENS
NEED TO HAVE TO ACHIEVE UPWARD
ECONOMIC MOBILITY.
IF YOU WANT A STAGNANT ECONOMY
AND ONE WHICH POOR AND
MIDDLE-CLASS AMERICANS ARE
LOCKED IN PLACE AND HAVE
ARTIFICIAL BARRIERS PUT IN THEIR
WAY BY GOVERNMENT, THEN THAT IS
WHAT YOU SHOULD DO.
OTHERWISE WE SHOULD EXPECT FREE
MARKETS.
NANCY PELOSI KNOWS BETTER AND
SHE OUGHT TO BE ASHAMED OF
HERSELF FOR SUGGESTING
OTHERWISE.
>> Shannon: WELL YOU ALL WILL